stinky big big thing welcome back to Gen
Julie podcast this is art on the table
in a suitcase mother vanity case
magazine today specifically brought you
by nature box if you're going to connect
be smart about it
all right oh yeah smack and coffee with
nature box right yeah yeah you are
giving you 50% off your first order when
you hit a naturebox.com/tyler which
includes strawberry lemonade fruit stars
which are love and life and the best
snack I love them so much
that's like 30 bags of those 20 bags I
think we're out well I thought we'd
actually planter a good a good bit of
them anyway get yourself some major
vodka is delicious snacks smart and also
brought to you by me and II the reason
I've been talking about me and these for
months now they're the softest most
comfortable on the road your ever wear
once you try them you won't want to wear
anything else this month is a rainbow
confetti print right here
oh hell yeah celebrate oh I'm not on
these today by going to meet Ali Khan
flash Jenna Julie and you'll save 20%
off your first pair thank you sponsors
thank you sponsors we got to [ __ ]
legit og sponsors here two powerhouses
oh yeah I got my beep in his suitcase
and we just out here I'm a minion shawl
on and Seana it's like a different item
every year I'm a purple phase deal
Wisconsin chart that Julian had me
printed on last-minute trips
what's nice you know I'm just out you
loose in Memphis don't ever talk to me
and my son again
Marla's widget in history case on the
table he knows you're just listening
just imagine what for you to do to
rolling suitcase with a dog in it but it
has like mesh so you can see out of it
and he really likes it a lot well you
want to lay it down flat honey so that
you can have like like a little crate
sort of shall we shall we show it but
totality look at this oh my god so we
have rolled around called the snoozer
well hello there
okay I'm going to tip you alright it's
gonna be very disorienting for a second
all there he go Wow my goodness
alright now let me just fix your blanket
before you crawl away okay here we go
Julian done got up and turned the fan on
because he's had it what doesn't be he's
hot because he's had it we're literally
making daddy hot from how frustrated he
is here it's just like in this room
alright fix your little bomb so you can
put all of you on the blanket honey
Wow good struggle noise okay how's that
good okay
now you sit there and then mommy's gonna
open up this second goofy on all mock
it's like you have a moonroof
what el my goodness and then I'm gonna
roll it up and okay if you clicked it
not the middle noggin okay and then oh
ma Wow we now we have a little quick I'm
sorry for bumping it into something you
can just lay back down it's okay Oh
oh my god there you go there you go okay
know how to give a static I wasn't going
to talk period oh wow marble it's a
marble rolling suitcase yes for you yeah
oh yeah yeah level come this way poke
your head out this roof I don't think he
knows we're here I don't think you can
you hey hey yo move comes okay come here
look it oh wow
would you
Wow bud I will come back over here me
living oh there he goes Wow
so thank you marble for joining us thank
you marble for that wonderful segment
surprised you like me like it all its
effects I think Buffy flexi or has an
ounce of patience for me at all
speaking of you on the last episode of
our podcast one of the top class episode
yeah which I did honest was that we
should do don't even get me started
which is like a ranting you don't even
get me started and how does it work you
basically pick a topic or thing out of
it I put a minute on that cup and
whatever it is you just gotta stop get
me started
not they're not all like that some of
them are good but some of them are
definitely like for me or for you
yeah so the video it'll be random but
there's a couple personal personalized
ones that we put in there for like
specifically one of our don't eat get
started get me started on this game
which is called don't even get me
started are playing he doesn't wanted it
so we said why not Jenna's gonna pull
from the Hat first and here we go don't
even get Jenna started and thank you for
your comment and your suggestion thank
you very much okay let's do it every
week guys we check the comments for new
suggestions so just keep them oh this
says renting your house don't even get
me oh okay for what we're sitting in
this room it doesn't need to do that
anything the house ideas a lot for that
search for the first lay on the cover
we're sitting in in this room let's
address this room and you guys can't
even see what's going on a door that
goes to the outside behind us and I
think we have termites over there
because we like termite dust better
definitely don't not have termites and
so our green screen you know which a lot
of you guys actually funded for us when
we started the twitch stream early if
we're going to get a green screen that's
what we did we invested
into the green screen so we could have
this place to play video games and do
the podcast and it has water damage on
the end of it right over here because
the door that is full of termite dusts
and things has a giant gap and during
that like three months period of like we
got non-stop torrential rain in Southern
California for some reason it got water
damage on it along with the garage and
like all kinds of stuff
our plumbing in this house is god-awful
like we have to tell people I'm really
sorry with the Plumbing's like terrible
so there are more toilets in this work
that in this house that don't work than
work right we have like two working
toilets and it's 2.5 for some toilets
which in our house which is nice but we
should have more than that like in our
bedroom for example it's not nice that
having a more intro that's in a house
with like six bedrooms or like six rooms
like toilet in the bedroom doesn't
really work parallel life that's the
worse going back to your other point
though don't even get me started on the
gaps underneath every single door to the
outside we're we had a cockroach walk
into the living room the other day well
the doors open yeah I don't know that's
where it came from and it came from
constant what makes you think that even
the living room came from the kitchen
we'd never had a cockroach that's not so
much the issue Jeff if I kind of good to
see ya not like a problem what about the
one that I found over here wrapped up
for you for Christmas there was that was
really sweet by the way that's what I'm
saying that dad what I need to go it's
not necessarily because that the kitchen
door was open for a half an hour
notice the gaps and needs the doors like
an inch big yeah so if we lived in
anywhere with real weather we would
likely freeze well yeah that's a real
thing like you you cover your windows
with towels and saran wrap it's up to
save heat and everything yeah but also
like your door you put like a thing
under there for a draft because it would
cost you a fortune to heat and cool the
place you another thing every winter I
think every single Christmas it's
tradition for our office to just
completely start leaking so as an early
gift in the holidays instead of you know
Christmas caroler carolers or some sort
of dessert we get some water in the
office and of course it's like that room
right like the most I landlord my
landlord assured us I was like right
when we saw this I was like this
water damage on the floor and he was
like yeah but it was a leak and it's
totally fixed now and I'm like are you
sure like it he's like yeah no it's all
fixed it's all fixed son like all right
because one thing about making this an
office like there's going to be just
about every piece of electronic
equipment that we good morning because
like we the first time we looked at the
house we went in the office room and we
looked at me like up you like some
discoloration on the ceiling I wonder if
there's a lot of areas we brought up
with but he assured us completely fine
now
we've been here for three years in
October every single year there's been a
leak some sometime in the holiday season
area like Christmas like December
January and yeah that's cool that's
[ __ ] clear it's like the worst start
to me about renting your place is that
if stuff goes wrong you have to tell
your landlord and then it's up to them
about how and when they fix it how is
the most important thing right it's not
when they say yes how he has his own
like crew of people that are like in
cahoots with him that will do things you
know we'll be like this is broken can
you send someone to come fix it and be
like sure sure no problem
and he'll send his buddy over and
they'll do something that like really
doesn't fix the problem at all and you
know that he picked that person because
he's paying a little to no money for it
man so that's that's been nothing
nothing ever gets takes nothing or they
either opera we fix so you don't have
actually Danny they put on top of them
right but then you get to live there
yeah though there's they're mad why
don't even get me started on there was
one repair that the landlord called and
had someone come that fixed it was our
gate it was the only time I they ever
sent a repair that actually fixed a
problem
every other time no don't even get a
starter guys because we'll just start
complaining at you about this house and
renting it but I like this house I like
living here it just would be nice if we
could fix things yeah
like after that big rain in the leak and
everything like the garage is falling
apart the feeling of the garage got all
of my car but we're just hanging out in
our room or we're gonna fall through the
garage I shouldn't have got you started
guys my day
yes so man people with dark suitcases no
how dare you don't even get me started
what is wrong with people with dog
suitcases okay maybe I would have got
here for this
you have a dog yet maybe I would have
been that person I was range of our dog
suitcases before I was a person with the
dog suit there's no way I didn't read
this
glad you got it you wrote anything with
dog suitcases why do you even have a dog
and why does that dog have legs look at
him he that was not a job he's done
walking he decided he was done walking
for his birthday and I'm on an honor
guard
he is a glorified yeah oh yeah that's
even a little too much credit faboo why
why are you taking them into cases I
mean I hate raising lights again for
marble it kind of works because he
really is just like this all right like
a little rap my bad boom where we will
rat you like it in there to me she's
happy he just he's become so so uh honey
why deny his happiness I don't I just I
can't argue for this I'm this personal
and by default I'm this person a will
you wheel him around in the snow I will
never wheel him around unless you ask me
to no absolutely welcome ready well you
really folded pretty quickly there's no
test all right let me look yeah I
remember a future we we all know man
yeah you know I mean like fully extended
walking around public are you kidding me
dude I'll [ __ ] win over anyone looks
at me weird I'll be like dude if you're
going to a thermometer happy he is if
you're gonna look at someone with that
look today he probably picked me as the
right person to look at like that no I
think I think like I was the same as you
like before we got the star CDs for
miles we were like Oh dodge teaches like
what a [ __ ] show that is like why would
you ever do that their dogs they walk
he loves it but not only is he getting
old I mean you know he sees that he's
nine which you know to make some healthy
and everything but he's definitely like
lost
see the desire to be an active animal
and you know like he's fine just City
money he appreciates like a little walk
but that's about it
like use your honor I do not he's never
going to let go play in the yard is like
chasing Zoar play fetch or give a scared
about anything he really doesn't care
what he just wants to sit for the rest
of his life okay you can do that
I feel bad ray I think Marla I'm sorry I
love you he likes this week AIDS okay
you pick now to the piping affordable
alternative to walking p80 w it's a CA
TW guys it's a pot Bob what is possible
where's little pot we put them in it
some 2pi shopping another wonderful year
bottle ah you big another anything my
rant about it
Gilda diamonds in there you don't even
go get heavy sorry not you be busy in
Jody is Debbie's dog and we're watching
guilty for a couple days so gillies with
us so we have four dogs guilty the first
thing about guilty is she doesn't like
to do what I say seriously - doesn't
listen to you uh I said guilty come and
she stays and I walk at her and she runs
underneath the table away from me I
tried to see her and she runs away I try
to take her for a walk and she runs away
hi
I beg you lease it she barks she's the
sweetest little girl but she doesn't
know where I love her so much
listen to me a little bit yeah well you
have your weird like language with dogs
that I don't have well the thing that's
really funny to me about guilty is that
she's like her whole body is super hard
feeling a hard yeah it's like the
opposite of all three of our dogs cuz
they're a strong team so mushy and
utterly and Gobi it's just like a hard
stop it yeah but I caught her when we
let Picchu run out in the front yard
because teach you loves that
Gibby
jammed her head under the fence and
tried to wiggle her hard sausage body
out into the street it's just don't even
get me started on guilty because guilty
is a terrier and it's like the complete
opposite of the dogs we have really
hungry oh she's a dog he's basically
kept like like really really tame weird
cats and then we simply have a dog in
the house who behaves like a proper dog
would she eat my fluency second dealing
in this carpet around I like pees and
poops on walks
Yeah right like like needs to get out
and like you know do her thing and we'll
dig and try to get through a fence like
our dogs are like literally not that at
all you know concave like that they have
none of those mannerisms I guess in that
sense I've never actually had a dog yeah
we've never had any dog because even the
dogs I had before I met you like my
mom's dog puppy like puppies not a dog
l-fatiha
a marble like a glorified little
daughter yeah look at it she probably
gets carried more than marble does yeah
puppies oh my god puppies my mom brings
puppies dead literally everywhere she
goes
your mom's lights and your mom sewed
handles onto a dog thank you if you can
imagine yeah yeah Aragog ready fold in
half like a taco she sold me sewed
handles on the top so she could carry
the dog like a [ __ ] briefcase Oh
puppy would be sleeping like at your
mom's house she'd just fold it grab the
handles carrier put her in the car fold
it driver take her out so it's like
puppy doesn't even move when she travels
to see her she never really snaps at
people which is like a puppy Siri can
say all things about Jodi she's a
sweetheart and it's been a joy to have
her she'll be okay the delis default
position is mouth open
feet out that's another thing see that's
another thing so we'll still go in for
like licks and you'll get teeth and
you'll be like guilty stop it now guilty
and you know what's nice is like she is
she she's used to sleep in a crate but
when we watch dogs we don't really do
what they normally do we like I was like
mommy I just sleep in the bed and I was
like if she wants to bring the fun on
glass which is like Brandi loves to
sleep
she sleeps in Julian's legs yeah so
guilty has been sleeping with me which
is nice I really enjoy that so yeah
she's really cute she's cute but she
you're naughty naughty she not worried
is our guard eyes are the naughtiest
chin peach like we've already linked in
our living room with a picture on it a
peach tearing up toys you have a peach
card in there so oh yeah I have the same
picture oh this is mine no all right
morning talk shows what did you write
this morning talk shows well host drink
wine oh my god do it don't even get me
started
hold it copy and you [ __ ] gasoline or
whatever the [ __ ] what are you doing
with your time no more energy I don't
understand that I can't get into it
because it just feels like a I don't
know if you've ever met anyone that's an
alcoholic or like a recovering alcoholic
yeah that the message of whatever you
guys are trying to do like having fun
with a casual morning fun talk show
you're just reiterating that you guys
are middle aged women and the only way
for you to like get loose and have fun
is to have a 7:00 a.m. glass of
chardonnay like that's ridiculous
this isn't a joke by the way like I like
ask you if you're curious about if this
exists because I was I when I'm
super-psyched want and believe it's 7:00
in the morning we were in Texas for
South by and I turned on the TV while I
was getting ready and it was 9 a.m. 9
something a.m. Texas time which is 7
something a.m. Eliane and they're
sitting there with line glass yeah not
only is that like for me it's like
confusing because it's like that when
I'm watching morning shows I want to
relate to what I'm watching right I want
to watch them having their coffee I want
to watch them talking about traffic
whatever when they're sitting there with
glasses of wine I can't not only can I
not relate but I feel so frustrated at
the fact that that's ok and it's like
people watch the families watch this is
this just spreading the message that
this is OK relations have line in the
morning I just don't understand it would
be hard for me if I was you know not
that any show should cater to any
particular audience would be really hard
for me if I was like recovering from an
addiction or alcohol or something and
you can't even watch a morning show at
CCA you can't even watch like the way
that you would like to get your
information that is without watching
people get drunk it's not anything they
don't go hand in hand to me I don't know
who decided that that connection was the
thing well it's like I imagine if I was
in recovery and I was going to watch Sam
football game I know that there's going
to be like a ton of the commercials for
beer and I'm aware of that and you're
ready for a nice people they're drinking
and if you aren't sitting there no no
that's not my point that's not my point
when you're when you're in certain
settings and your sensitive jobs are
thing you can prepare yourself you know
for that setting morning talk shows
you're like that's the last thing you'd
expect yeah this is this is just traffic
this enews like this is just like stupid
things that I can just like mindlessly
get ready to and there's a good wine
list I'm not even sensitizes you to it
that's exactly it's exactly right
oh I'm also 45 year old women or 50
something or whatever and you know
they're having a glass of wine at 7:00
in the morning so why can't I so maybe I
should and then that how you get a
problem yeah also I baby when they have
the wine they start they start behaving
like incredibly like I've seen them be
really rude I was watching I forget
their name because I don't I don't
really know who any other bar but there
was a show that it was a morning show
I'm not even heard a copy I can't
remember but one of them was in the
studio when Amazon on like the street
you know live and in the studio the one
who was the anchor there was with Bill
Nye and she was being said questions to
ask Bill Nye like science questions and
he would be Bill Nye be hilarious and
charming and answer them and be awesome
and as he was answering these questions
that were you know sort of scientific
but also like he was giving them in
layman's terms so everyone could
understand it she was literally rolling
her eyes and like it was like like
visibly just being annoyed and tea and
like producers were laughing and it was
like a bit that they were just like
mocking
the guest and I couldn't understand it
like it wasn't reddit that's why I saw
it because I wasn't watching it and that
was the first time I was like wow I like
really just don't like this at all this
whole culture of like this is my like
morning show or I'm gonna be the sassy
you know wine drinking host and
whoever's in my way like get out of here
with this like actual content and and
intelligence
get off my set with that yeah I mean I
feel like there's plenty of shows where
drinking or you know that type of thing
makes sense to me but there's something
about a news related morning show that
just doesn't say wine to me yeah you
know yeah don't even get us started on
that too late you got us started on it
it just feels weird to do girls
it feels own but I also like I feel like
it comes from a world and as to most
people where like when you go to work
you you don't get to be drunk
when you go to school you don't get to
be drunk like they're drinking and being
professional or two different things you
know not that I'm one to talk is I've
made tons of drunk videos and we've had
drinks on the podcast but I think that
there's a difference between making
something inherently light-hearted or
like I don't do I totally am just
everything like the norm of getting to
work and pouring yourself a glass of
wine yeah it becomes about that rather
than that one yet Haitian in the
Egyptian podcast major joint videos are
the exception of the world you don't
miss drunk videos you have made resident
I have done drug podcasts but it's like
it's we podcast it every day and every
day we drink on the papaya but funny
regard yeah in the time of data that's
[ __ ] why yeah I think I would die
I can't drink every day well yeah I mean
I would be sick yeah I mean like the
biologic yeah like the effect really
alcohol alone I know like but not
speaking in terms of that like that
aside the actual physical and
physiological effects of drinking that
much of that early like aside just I
don't know if that's the content I would
be wanting to put out I want to be
taking part of that in the world but
people love them oh my gosh oh my god I
love getting my news from you give your
glass of wine well I don't think young
people love them throwback no no no
young people with that I don't think
right not that I know
I'm really even watch that showbiz it
feels like garbage yeah sorry
alright don't get that jar no no offense
no no offense
I'm offense alright my - don't even get
me started on people who abused area
chat
that's yours oh don't even get me
started
well I'm playing a lot of Elder Scrolls
obviously what is area chaplain so you
put on your headphones or whatever and
there's voice channels so you can be in
like your guild channel you could be in
the general area chats with people
around you if you're going to group
you're doing a dungeon you deem your
dungeon Chad talk to the other people in
the dungeon so I like to always be on
area chat so like any time ride them a
horse around and all just sure people
are talking and there are people that
just straight up like leave their mics
on and then like blast music into the
area jet like some of the most foul like
like so much explicitly religious and
when you know that there is like
thirteen-year-old kids playing that game
listening to the area chat who also
engage in the most foul language insults
to each other yeah it's insane it's been
happening for centuries an online video
game right right even when I was playing
Halo there's a player unknown Bal ground
area chat and it's all full of like
racist all here [ __ ] tolerate though I'm
not [ __ ] here yeah you hear what then
you understand what I mean ever turn no
but I like almost don't believe you
because I feel like even when you want
so but that's that's a crazy thing right
like that game and it's not it's not
like that but okay you were lying back
to like 2005 or whatever whenever like a
halo came in yeah I don't know exactly
here but when you got on that and the
dawn of Xbox Live started and it was
like you're playing online video games
with other people and you can talk to
them with your headset and you never see
their face but I'll never see your face
anyone or eachother lid and you only
read my tags no one know y'all are
autonomous gamertag right that was like
for me at least I know it existed before
this on PC gaming and a lot of other
platforms but for me that was the first
time I was exposed to just like like
talking [ __ ] on online video game right
like you want
it's like you know like you know
supermodel your mom sucks like you know
anyway but it was like horrible things
that people would say to each other
on the regular racist things included
you hear it all the time
and now you fast forward to 2017 where
it's like online video games have only
gotten infinitely more advanced and
prevalent you know on different
platforms and so I was playing pub G and
to hear that it's like wow like people
are really still shitty people like
really serious about it yeah we haven't
involved at all in that sense but I
agree with you is it for me it's like it
takes you out of that experience where
you're like there's so much about
there's so much positive that comes with
playing online video games in a game you
like cuz you're like I'm competing with
other people at this game we both love
there something really cool about that
and then you hear like someone blast a
bunch of [ __ ] nonsense and chatter me
like oh I kind of hate everything like
why am I even on here plus I play a lot
with people because you you match up
randomly for dungeons a lot yeah and
they'll have a headset on and you'll
heal here and it shows you a little icon
about when your mic is like being yeah
yeah it tells you when you're when your
eyes yeah but it amazes me how many
people sit with their headset on and go
[Laughter]
and you can pick and see that their
money is going and they don't [ __ ] do
anything about it don't even get me
started
why can you not see in the bottom right
corner of your whole screen that your
mic is going off right now like figure
it out use yourself for 5 SEC knew
yourself and forget to say something
like what are you doing like you just
have to sit there and listen to them
like breathe and struggle noise and this
like the button pushing sound here hold
on this [ __ ] some sitting in the living
room and all you can hear alright I'm
totally [ __ ] here it goes
all you can hear is this through your
headset
like louder than the game but I could
stop announce I'm ready oh my god I hate
that but um I'm trying to think of some
of the funniest ones the one the other
day when I was sitting in like Julian
come here like he was listening to a
song that was so explicit I can repeat
none of the lyrics then he kept chanting
them out loud afterwards too and then he
kept saying he would call out specific
other people's usernames Oh nobody duel
this [ __ ] little [ __ ] yeah
thanks it's probably good start in
Europe that's it though that's like it's
that culture it's like explodes it's
like you're on anonymous gaming live and
do whatever you want man it's super
funny
volleyball I also until I started
playing elder scrolls I did not realize
how many people play like super high
yeah that's the thing but like if I were
to play a video game and I was into like
getting super high I feel like I
wouldn't want to play online with other
people
like to party to around to each their
own but like I don't know how I could
just get super high me like you knows
that dude yeah it's like a weird miryo
type dname though you know what's your
name Mina Kaelyn we're playing with this
guy that literally I don't know what it
meant he wouldn't explain what it meant
but he would be like I hold on to your
group before is like hold on a second
I'm going to take a hit you're like okay
then do you whatever and then you just
come in gotta keep stick and I'm just
gonna stick he's negative stay calm
stick those are like hard drugs and [ __ ]
no not Jesus Christ Mary couldn't
breathe you have to keep stacking up
good what does that mean he's stacking
them you're not sucking in like I've
never done the dungeon before and we're
like alright what do we do here and use
like a he's got a sec I'm seeing a
keepsake and I'm thinking what
I don't know I don't know I don't know
his life don't even get me started on
people who don't wear comfortable
wonderful me undies oh my god and get me
started I've been telling you guys about
me any for so long and the reason is the
sauce is underwear you ever put on your
bum okay they are softer than cotton
okay it's made of modal fabric
sustainably sourced and made from micro
model fabric that's three times software
cotton guys if we're used to buying
packs of uncomfy boring stiff underwear
that can only come in gray black or tan
me and these will change that for you
okay
this is this this month's design
actually okay it's actually really nice
it's called celebrate it's the rainbow
pack enough to celebrate guys it's
decide we're announcing holiday right
now you guys can go on me ah nice calm
and check out all of their different
designs this is just one of them they
come out with new original designs every
single month which is so cool and let me
tell you there's nothing cooler and and
nicer for your wardrobe to get a fresh
new set of undies every single month you
don't realize how much you need that
until you get me and it's pretty awesome
try me me undies today right now by
going to me undies calm go right now
before celebrate pattern is gone they
will lead to you have to get them while
they're hot me and e-commerce annejulien
get 20% off your first pair you have to
feel for yourself why me Andes has this
been on you but before I possibly Julian
would you put my face yeah clean dirty
so gonna press out of the package
thank you $20 and free shipping me any
evidence on you know what ed what you
think I'm gross do you know I'm I just
get so triggered that I put my finger on
my eye and I move my contact and I can't
really see any more so I caused you to
do that your thing
all right I also brought to you by
nature barks guys you're gonna snack
snack smart about it
all right guys don't touch the shampoo
daddy get naturebox this is our favorite
one it's strawberry lemonade food starts
and let me tell you how awesome nature
boxes I've talked about this snack like
100 times and they were like you know
what [ __ ] it we're going to send them
2020 a box of 20 of these in you know in
a package to us they normally send this
like an array of different snacks they
were like no we listen to you guys we
know what you like so right now you guys
head over to nature box I'll have a look
at their map massive snack catalogue
there's a hundred to choose from pick
your faves and they get delivered right
to your door which is really nice you
don't have to go shopping for them and
you have to worry about bad ingredients
and insane things going in your snack
you can get nature box whether you're
vegan gluten-free or looking for low fat
no added sugar naturebox there's always
snacks for you and if you ever try a
snack you don't like they will replace
it for free look at Li around VP so you
can order as much as you want as often
as you want with no minimum purchase and
you can cancel anytime
right now go to naturebox.com/tyler
Julianne and they are giving you 50% off
your first order with that URL guys
check it out you won't be sorry
you'll like it Jen I can't see out every
contact what just happened
it's not good it's not like our
detergent that's my leave butt plate no
doesn't get there cream I got it out of
the laundry Stephan telling about all
right moving on oh yes I'm so glad I
picked this or a lot are you doing I'm
terrible at foot onions and then ask you
for that enjoy my life buddy over here
now don't even get me started I can't
set up it's not my fault
why'd you contact you oh god it's coming
out my god it is coming out what the
[ __ ] dude no you always let you finish
should I talk about what's out oh no
fine the clown well I know like this
might hurt to put it back in
I can talk about like not fit into my
little universe or yoga oh it was
actually okay the hands are very clean
right we'll do a couple more we'd also
do all of them fine that's fine
all right don't even get me started
I'm Katy Perry you to blush
oh no honey me to get loud for this one
I know I'm just confused
honestly all okay when I first saw that
Katy Perry was on YouTube and going live
and doing yoga and meditation and some
like random videos I was like first I
was like curious I was like yes me
what I said it's Katy Perry youtuber I
don't hear because I didn't know I was
like is this just something I don't know
is she youtuber and like I just didn't
understand so she does these watches and
actually today there's one actually
currently going on and I'm not sure I
still happy I always I thought I'm not
sure if it's still happening by the time
podcast goes live but you may change
isn't it you want to charge her lawyers
called witness so you're like being
witnessed her life to get it it's it
it's stupid I don't like it I think it's
stupid
I think I think this this live stream
that she's done has given me an insight
into who she is as a person that I don't
like and like I felt zero away about
Katy Perry before we were talking about
it I guess I'm you know the music skits
like I don't really care I don't like
her or dislike her I feel nothing about
her but then I saw these large teams and
I saw like how she was acting and how
she was treating her producers and
assistants and guests and just like
acting in general and I was like I don't
like your attitude like you're just kind
of a mean person it feels like and
you're just displaying that on the
internet like for whatever reason to
promote your album or whatever it is
like it just it all felt really weird to
me okay so they're in a Katy Perry I
just want to get a little little
disclaimer here I'm not hating on that
like you can be a fan of whoever you
want I'm wrong I imagine if you are a
fan of Katy Perry her live streams
appear to them very different than it
appeared to you 100% precise and like
reads in multiple different ways yeah
listen a little time back
any parry take a 15 minute meditation
break and then no wake up wake up and
yell at people downstairs to be quiet
quiet like you're in a production house
follows people like how can anybody be
quiet what I'm wondering though is like
does she not realize that this is all
alive and like it's not the greatest
look to be just like yelling at people
and being mean to people well a lot of
the comments are people being like I
love Katy Perry this just shows like how
cool the person she is like I mean
that's what some people are seeing to me
I definitely agree with you that I saw
some things that made me be like oh my
gosh Lee
they were sitting down watching a bunch
of her videos because I watched because
I saw Elijah like oh she tweeted out a
link that's using me on there like
that's so [ __ ] rad because everybody
likes Liza and so I go there and watch
and it felt very much like she talked
Allies over three seconds and I'm not
watching her own video no no man her two
friends like her actual friends came in
and she sort of just like dropped Eliza
and let Liza walk around and introduce
herself to the other people in the house
and then hung out with her two friends
then they sat down and watched some of
Katy Perry's videos her own videos and
she liked all except in the middle like
as if that's not you know whatever plans
out yeah but it's good but again if
you're a Katy Perry super fan that's
super cool because you're watching Katy
Perry watch our own videos and talk
about things that happen you know I mean
I can understand why some people are
like this is so rad and other people are
like wow this is pretty self-absorbed
but during all of that so you've liza
Koshi on the couch and her like stylist
or you know people that she works as and
his friends with she just turns around
like in the middle kept being like pause
pause we're going to go back okay that
yeah oh my god just screenshot that okay
yeah keep going and then she turns
around she goes can I get a humidifier
please like today your average person
seems so outrageous but to her that's
like you know her life and she just
asked the person first minified him
again I don't know her story
which is like well okay and I don't know
her what her life's about I don't know
her as a person I don't know anything
anything no I didn't know I did not see
like like a wrong decision went from
going from going from not showing any of
this or any of you know who she is or
whatever a planned or live or not live
to just live streaming her kind of
snapping at people it's not like to meet
at least like you know there's a lot of
ways to do the whole telethon model I
think that she's trying to do for promo
or whatever it is that I think works and
one way is to like make sure your talent
is acting incredibly appealing and not
like the way she's been acting hmm like
I I am like there was she did a fiery
confession many people to think that
what she's doing is appealing I don't
think so I don't know how that's
possible it's a about is like a therapy
session and posted it to YouTube like
what the [ __ ] is that
yeah don't get me started on what that
means what even is that get me started
on there
she just and she talks but she's pretty
zonked out I can't I got her I mean I
think I got I'm not asking you to I'm
just I'm just saying like the tone of
voice just sounds really completely out
of it uh-huh I feel like I just probably
offended a lot of Katy Perry fans but
I'm I'm just trying to be honest like it
was just a very weird thing to turn on
YouTube and see what's on live and well
I mean think of it this way Katy Perry
just performed at the YouTube creator
summit like which was cool but you also
don't know what this deal looks like
with YouTube Janine so this could be
like she's signed a deal with YouTube to
do this 24 hour livestream for however
many days leading up to the release of
her album like this which is why we have
youtubers going on there Patrick Starr
and Isaac OC and stuff it feels like a
gigantic cross-promotion inked on paper
a long time ago and parts of it do
definitely feel like Katy Perry doesn't
exactly want to fulfill some aspects of
the 24 hour livestream like maybe in
theory it seems like it's a cool thing
to agree to like yeah you're gonna put
you in this house and it's all just like
we'll have friends come over and like
you hang out and just do it ever you
want but it's like it's a 24 hour grind
for her you know which I imagine [ __ ]
sucks but but that's
that's what happens when you sign a deal
to stream 24 hours live with YouTube
you're going to have youtubers on their
the Katy Prairie probably doesn't know
either yeah you're going to have a lot
of things to do that you don't really
know or care about so I don't understand
why she's coming up or a snobby if
you're put this is also like you you
have Liza Koscheck Eliza cost you on
here like I could have done with a
little more respect you know and I mean
it felt very like oh my god you're so
cute
okay let's watch my music videos now
that's what I was like how disrespectful
the Liza taking time out of her schedule
everyone in this comment section right
now say where's Liza like you cannot
deny that this person and YouTube knows
that that this person is contributing to
your your promotion that you know people
are coming to watch Katy Perry because
they're huge Eliza co-chief is open and
it's all very [ __ ] weird so I don't
know
it is Liz's but don't even get George
I'm really curious to know if like any
of you guys saw it and South even
remotely how I felt or if maybe you
didn't see it at all or maybe decide you
really enjoyed it I'd like to know why
or like what your thoughts were because
it was one of those ones where I watched
it I was like it just feels really I was
like I don't understand I'm looking at I
don't know why it's here I don't know
what's going on well it does feel on
YouTube a little out of place and that
they have this beautiful production
house with cameras everywhere clearly a
gigantic team of people making that
happen and cut from camera to camera to
camera as she walks through every single
room in the house like you're talking
Big Brother it's type of production
value you know and like I forgot I was
just going to [ __ ] say oh it seems
weird because it's on YouTube and you
have all this production and it's live
and you know people usually Big Brother
even the set look like this well usually
when people are live on YouTube a
they're not traditional celebrities and
be our version of live feels much more
offensive to people with your laptop
it's too [ __ ] WebKit right like if she
was going to be live for 24 hours a day
and even just stuck a laptop like in her
room I feel like that would be more
exciting than this fake promo like
having friends over and dinner and
conversations you know yeah also I
probably be a lot easier for Katy Perry
yeah because you'd be like oh is she
going to come in here I guarantee
more people watching the livestream of a
laptop set up in her room where she
might walk by or sit there and hang out
or let you know anyone that's true then
the weirdly produced things that that is
the last room that she did or is doing
it's on right now I think yeah it is
every girl's just me though that was a
nice cup of tea and someone's gonna
livestream
like think about a gaga just set up a
laptop in a room and then like I would
get like it was exciting whatever
anyways pulp-free orange juice I hand
this over to you because I get my son I
like why are you censoring oranges and
oranges I hate I hate this whole
phenomenon about Peeta and cold pizza I
like cold pizza and I like poultry
orange juice not that I have one with
pulp I have my I have my own in a pretty
heated debate a couple months back about
pulp versus no pulp and or juice and
Twitter tweeted at me saying at Twitter
said I think the results are in and and
it was a you know remember when they
held at the sign of the wrong people at
the yeah it was that but it says Pope
they're like no no plans or whatever so
I got told by Twitter that I was wrong
but let me just say this okay people
will often say when I say I like pulp
emeritus why don't you just eat orange
why is that thing why does that have
anything to do with orange juice just
because it comes from oranges doesn't
mean I want to have a physical snack
I still enjoy the beverage I just like
it the way it came out of the fruit the
way it was made if you're taking the
pulp out of it you're censoring it now
let me I'll concede that people who have
an aversion to like solid pieces in
their food in their drink rather like
that's weird for them I get that that
like some people can't drink something
that has little bits or something
whatever that's fine but for people who
are like I like I think orange juice is
nasty with pulp because pulp is nasty
and oranges should have no pulp where is
it respect it came from pulp that's what
it is and it's delicious have you ever
had like freshly squeezed orange juice
right out of the orange with you
everything you know you know
like orange juice or any pulp because
it's still good to me
I mean I'll drink it but the whole time
I just keep wishing it was like real
orange orange juice with no pulp in it
Walker it works at any hotel that we're
in and we get breakfast most of the time
since those are poor nice also turn
there you're telling me all the like
Best Westerns and stuff okay yes we're
the orange juice concentrate comes out
of a [ __ ] machine mixed with water
that you always have pulping them you
ride here's my higher ride like a rug
well here's my hierarchy what aren't you
support uh-huh or just no Papa nothing
instead of having nothing I'll take
oranges with no pulp I just would highly
vehement ly prefer that it had pulp in
it and I don't understand the logic that
goes behind saying orange juice should
be without Paul what about how like nasi
it makes your like cup your glass oh I
love it
that's gross love it like drive and gets
hard ah it's so good yeah so getting
wonderful no it's natural it's natural
well name something else that you drink
that has the same consistency as orange
juice with pulp because people like that
don't like stuff drinks with bits in
their drink like I can't really op top
my head think of something else that you
drink on regular basis it has a texture
like that
Frappuccino no that's an ice i tried huh
I'm thinking of like um you know some
kombucha is have like chia seeds in them
or whatever yeah but like I said like
certain people have an aversion to
things in their liquid but name
something else that people drink on a
regular basis that has that consistency
because I can't think of any so I can
understand what some would be like it
would be easier to make you do not just
what you need yeah but that's also what
makes a nasty to something else you
don't say it's nasty boy you nasty and
you need Jesus I don't need you if I
have Jesus within my pocket all right
you want to do one more which one all
know you in a suitcase did you just
remember well he doesn't know where he
is
oh my god oh I think we got a drunk
guard
don't even get me started on how sexy ad
is because that boy is so sex today oh
yeah oh I mean yeah I'll go get him
you think he could be near marble know
what Marvel can be in his suitcase let's
try it because you're going to be
holding ad and marbles like you have the
leap across the table oh my god there's
a fly in that light you know he's in
that light oh my god I want to die
anyway so ad is super sexy but I feel
terrible because the other night I went
to go feed him and I don't know if you
do a lot of reading on hamsters like I
do but apparently you're supposed to not
just put their food in their dish you're
supposed to like sprinkle it around
their cage because they're foragers oh
okay because they're forager so they
like it's better for them to like run
around and have to find food and that's
more entertaining because if you just
put it in their dish then you'll end up
with a fat bored hamster really but um
the other night I was feeding him and I
had something else my hands so I was
going upstairs was going to go to bed
cuz I feed him at night like right
before I go to bed because that's when
he's like up and ready for breakfast so
I put his food like on the top of his
house he was in his little sand bath
like his potty and so I put the food on
top of his house like some of the seeds
and it made like kind of a loud noise
because it's plastic
I usually just sprinkle it on there and
for some reason it like sort of fell out
of my hand so it was more like you know
and he was in a potty and his only time
I've ever seen him go like this he went
like with his mouth open like I scared
him I'm putting the food on his house I
said no I scared him yet he opened his
mouth and was like king for any
denominator oh my god I was a good juicy
mommy baby show me a little fishy tale
right so cute Wow we started can you we
got a cameo they snuck in I opened the
door in second house not good I know
really how sexy is that I had a sexy man
the way he struts around with that long
fur his tail always gets his his his
bedding and sometimes his poop stuff in
his lair oh my god you get Matthew
open that but where boy when he walks
around late out tonight at 7:00 cleans
himself and he looks at you and then in
each spinach I mean he runs on his wheel
I mean he just exudes sex all he shakes
that ass and it's it's pure sex
what is [ __ ] wrong name is sexier
hamster oh wait I can't please
there is no sexier answer mm-hmm
make sure you don't want to do one more
oh do one more yeah you do one one I
can't believe this started off is a no
biggy podcast and it turns into a goose
I know that always seems to happen post
mates who make decisions for me don't
even get me started
ah it happens way more than you think it
would where you order something very
specific on post mates and and it comes
to your door a different thing
it's not what you ordered not even close
sometimes it's just another first well
the problem is it by the way it's an
incredibly personal problems and most of
these like rants are first well rants
but nonetheless we are there have been a
lot of times when we've ordered
something and they delivered something
completely different almost something
inedible because a lot of time you know
we're super difficult but we can ain't
mechanic and they instead calling or
texting or reaching out to us in any way
shape or form while at the store they
just decide that maybe they might be tie
or okay with this I know they asked for
this brand or this type or this thing
but this looks good enough and they get
it yeah and I'm like what what am I
paying you for at all what am i using
this app for I love post mates they're
great I use alone it's in a cage or a
person you get the occasional person
where you like yeah and you know you
just like you just wanted to like just I
am is it in then use wonder like hammer
this this this post mates drive out so
you can get the right cash out and leave
and like not do a job at all make sure
customers like a little satisfied as a
Cabasa don't want some of the worst ones
that we've had and post mates does like
fix the problem but yeah they reach
other your head cutter that's right but
the worst ones that I've had is whenever
I'm writing in order for post mates I
try to make it as specific as I can so
that they can't [ __ ] it up yeah
so I'll write like daya white deluxe
white cheddar mac
cheese vegan with mixed vegetables yeah
you know and I'll write in parentheses
like it's near the box mac and cheese
it's the vegan one you know it's like
holding orange jelly object you know
whatever and then they gave us boxes of
deluxe like regular carry maximum yeah
and you're like did you just only in
this it already you only read the word
deluxe they've got like the complete
opposite
I don't you can I think it's it's just
like a it's a it's kind of misjudged
what it is that they're being paid to do
they think it's just like I'm grabbing
something's and start giving it to you
it's not like I'm in the world of
customer service networks like I have to
get yeah be like so good some people are
amazing some people call you or like hey
they have these two flavors they have
one box did you tell the podcast about
when we got talked about at one time and
the guy had his fun with them no yeah I
think I did actually that we ordered was
we ordered talked about in the
description of what we ordered we wrote
vegan so they wouldn't you know mess it
up with like beans instead of me or
whatever and this dude brought his son
with him on posters I see a lot which is
really cool because if I was opposed me
I can bring my kids oh cool guys that
travels it with their girlfriend there's
nobody sad yeah yeah anyway he brought
his son and his son walks up to the gate
and actually helps him the food over and
he he says he says I think it's really
cool that you guys don't need animals
and I was like well it's like really
really cute and sweet and then I was
like thank you kid and the dad was like
yeah he said he saw that we're vegan on
the receipt he want to know what it
meant so I explained to him I was like
oh that's totally really cool but that's
such a nice way to explain it to your
kid yeah we don't eat animals I think
it's cool the kid is like six I think
it's really nice they could only do no
matter how I really see moment mom if I
did it in authority you though you'd be
doing oh my god whenever I order from
the Chipotle nearest I'm trying to
figure out if it's the post driver oh no
I don't wear digital Chipotle first my
love Jared someone that worship Oatley
every time I order from Chipotle they'll
write things on the lid that's like girl
come do my nails they always
thank you latest video in early sweet
it's kind of cool but they write it on
the box I should go in there and just
like who keep doing this to show you so
that games fun that is fun game thank
you guys for suggesting right don't even
get me started on REE Drummond in our
ice cream truck and it can't see chat
time paint paint anger don't get me
started on her with her just completely
breaking down on a camera and putting
her husband on the spot about if he
loves her or not and her marriage is
good oh my god oh my god do you remember
those yeah she was like she made herself
like a daytime cocktail and was sitting
there every night she's like this
reminds me of the first drink we ever
had against you member yeah yeah do you
think I'm pretty
he's like yesterday yes and it's like
yeah but like tell me do you love me
we're just like way in morning the ice
cream
damn we every are you okay mahlia no you
okay alright Rees not okay no when the
cameras are not rolling she's not okay
she needs her husband to love her man
she does
she takes afternoon now for she dreams
major drumman will you love Bri please
anyway this episode basically I know is
rocky by nature box and me and he's
basically brought to by REE Drummond Wow
it's almost miss we did birthday yeah
guys so I'm super thick say mom's going
to be three years old thank you for
watching this episode in all seriousness
I would like to know your responses to
what we ranted about specifically to
Katie great thing I'm interested in that
I want to hear you guys thoughts and
like I said poll keep in mind when you
suggest things in the comments we read
them and it could be your suggestion
that we do the next part yeah
so I think you have so much hungry week
and my eye
[Music]
[Music]